m
bienvenue à chaska dans le minnesota aux
états unis ce sera la capitale du golfe
pendant trois jours
aujourd'hui dans cette émission nous
allons voir tous les aspects de cette
ryder cup 2016 nous allons rencontrer à
les fans nous avons parlé de l'aspect
économique et deux aspects politiques et
bien sûr nous avons parlé de la ryder
cup 2018 qui se tiendra à saint quentin
en yvelines
c'est parti à pour une émission spéciale
à ryder cup les anoraks
mais
non
la mise en scène de tout ça est
particulièrement réussie par rapport à
d'autres riders de là où on est debout
en train de faire ce l'interview envoie
le petit grings en ahl practice on voit
le départ du 1 au revoir la scène pour
la cérémonie d'ouverture et de clôture
et envoie aussi le village public avec
ses restaurants on sépare et aussi ses
magasins ça c'est essentiel pour créer
une ambiance
en dehors du parcours c'est essentiel
parce qu'il y aura de l'ambiance sur le
parcours lors des matchs il est à 7
heures du matin ici à chaska les
golfeurs vient d'entrer sur le green les
supporters sont en délire ils viennent
pour encourager leur équipe il ya de
nombreux américains
mais évidemment des européens sont au
total vingt mille ha derrière moi pour
le premier coup de la journée je vais
les rencontrer
world of show gogo
j'adore ça d'émotion il y a des gens
géniaux qui sont venus pour encourager
les usa nous pouvons tout gagner
c'est une pure atmosphère nous ne
pouvons pas la comparer à une ambiance
classique l'ambiance est comparable à un
stade de football sakharov progrès c'est
le summum je crois des compétitions de
golf au delà des quatre grands tours ne
manquait à annuellement mais en plus ça
c'est un match leur contre les états
unis et c'est quelque chose qui nous
plaît c'est la plus grande compétition
le pays la prend très au sérieux et nous
sommes très fiers de cette victoire de
l'indépendance yade à peine effectuée
alors il n'y a pas que des as supporters
étrangers ici à zentane il ya également
quelques français en tout cas j'en ai
trouvé un comment vous vivez cette
compétition c'est extraordinaire je suis
vraiment ravi d'être ici c'est vrai que
j'ai pas vu beaucoup de français je suis
même quasiment le sol parmi 200 mille
américains alors il le soleil commence à
être un peu haut ils ont vu comment
savoir un peu de bière donc on hésite
quand même à dire qu'on est pour
l'europe parce qu'ils sont extrêmement
patriotes très très fiers de leur pays
et est ce qui était intéressant
d'ailleurs c'est que bon il ya des
joueurs britanniques qui défendent les
couleurs de l'europe et ils sont
vraiment à fond pour l'europe donc ça
fait plaisir de retrouver aussi les
joueurs britanniques dans cette ambiance
et vous avez vu une icône du sport
américain tiger woods voilà je l' ai vu
en chair et en os
ils étaient à cinq mètres de moi voilà
alors il a toujours une nuée de deux
fans et de et de supporters on peut pas
l'approcher mais effectivement j'ai vu
voilà donc c'est quand même une belle
journée vous pouvez mourir tranquille
c'est ce que vous avez dit enfin oui
c'est une des choses que je voulais
faire donc il en reste encore plein à
faire notamment dans deux ans ne
l'oublions pas il ya donc des fans
français mais il ya également des
volontaires français nous allons les
rencontrer
oui toi
on s'y inscrire en fait il ya 18 mois
environ sur le site du pitié voilà et
puis on indique qu'on compare les
anglais quand même pouvoir converser aux
états unis et donc voilà on est rentré
dans le staff des bénévoles comme ça on
a eu une réponse
on a suivi tout un tout un parcours
d'inscription aux fêtes et en a eu
réponse il ya à peu près un peu plus
d'un an on est super bien accueilli
c'est vraiment c'est bon enfant il ya
une super ambiance avec les volontaires
il ya pas beaucoup de volontaires
internationaux et 250 mai mais on fait
des supers contact
nous sommes à présent au media center le
centre média plus de 1200 journalistes
sont accrédités pour l'événement et ils
viennent du monde entier nous allons les
rencontrer
je suis ici pour sky doll sport je
m'occupe des médias sociaux facebook
twitter instagram et je trouve ce qu'il
se passe en dehors de la compétition
pour les fans de la ryder cup
je suis reporter pour une chaîne de golf
en chine c'est ma première expérience
sur une ryder cup et je suis très excité
d'être ici
après avoir vu les médias étrangers nous
allons voir les médias français cocorico
il y en a des dizaines
ici au media center nous allons voir le
consultant thomas levet alors je suis
avec thomas levet à présent thomas levet
qui consultant pour une chaîne
concurrente canal bus on peut le dire on
peut le site et vous qui êtes là où
quasiment h 24 ici vous le trouvez
comment ces media center on voit qu'il
ya une grosse organisation pour les
journalistes et pour pour tout le monde
oui oui c'est ça ressemble à ce qu'il ya
dans les tournants majeurs c'est c'est
un petit peu plus gros parce qu'il ya un
petit peu plus d'intérêt pour la ryder
cup on va tous les records avec plus de
1200 journalistes qui se déplace et à et
puis tout ça va c'est des
infrastructures incroyable et puis cédée
à une ambition de dingue avec des bus
des transports il ya médias même pas de
trafic c'est ça qui est incroyable pour
arriver au greffe n'y a pas de trafic
alors que vous avez 60 mille personnes
qui se déplacent en même temps et c'est
juste une organisation très très bien
pensé et pour nous bat en france pour
2018 ça donne beaucoup d'idées ça donne
beaucoup de très bonnes idées d'ailleurs
et est donc on essaiera de faire aussi
bien
justement vous vous emmener sur la
prochaine question la ryder cup dans
deux ans en france c'est vraiment une
bonne idée ça va amener tout ça en
france un spectacle incroyable des
touristes américains il a mûri annonce
pratiquement vingt mille américains qui
vont se déplacer pour la ryder cup à
paris vous imaginez
le truc pour les hôtels les golfs toutes
les régions et puis la france est un
pays assez méconnu au niveau de la
qualité de ses golfs et de ses capacités
d'accueil pour les golfeurs donc je
crois que pour le département
78e ça va être absolument fabuleux moi
vous savez je m'entraînais à versailles
dont je connais bien le
le truc est et puis ça va être fabuleux
pour paris pour toute la france
d'accueillir un événement comme ça et je
pense que ça va donner pas mal d'idées
aux jeunes pour pour s'y mettre
après avoir visité le media center nous
sommes maintenant devant l'écran géant
dazelle times ils sont plusieurs
milliers à venir chaque jour ici pour
encourager leurs protégés
on peut voir en direct l'évolution des
scores et les matches
oh
je suis désormais devant l'un des
endroits les plus prisés ici au golf
dazelle times je ne vous parle pas des
écrans géants ou des green ou des
boutiques je vous parle bien sûr de la
buvette chaque américain et chaque
européen devrait boire selon les
organisateurs entre 5 et 10 litres
pendant les trois jours de compétition
je suis à présent et que jean-loup
charron le président de la fédération
française de golf
alors jean loup vous êtes ici dans le
minnesota qu'est ce que vous pensez de
cette ryder cup déjà leurs premières
impressions une notion d' espaces on
voit que les américains ont utilisé
beaucoup beaucoup de surface pour rendre
les choses plus fluide et créer un
événement assez exceptionnel car c'est
la première fois que la ryder cup
s'installe dans minnesota sur un
parcours qui a accueilli les plus grands
événements leur fisc américain en dehors
de la ryder cup donc ravis d'être là le
temps y est une décoration à
l'américaine tout rouge pour soutenir
leur équipe ce qui sera différente de
nous dans deux ans en 2018 ouverte
nationale bien sûr besoin vraiment
excellent bien sûr l'accueil chaleureux
les d'américains sont chaleureux ils
partagent avec nous des événements
dramatiques et tragique
et lorsque l'on dit qu'on est français
ils ont une amitié une chaleur qu'ils
veulent transmettre et nous disent à
quel point il aime la france à vous êtes
ravi enchantés et ravis et puis quelque
part at dette en 2018 donc de vieillir
un peu et des graphes nationale
alors maintenant on va vous quitter jean
loup et je vais aller au stand du golf
national qui s'y attellent times on y va
tout de suite
je suis à l'entrée du golfe hazell times
ici à chaska juste derrière moi vous
l'aurez reconnu c'est le stand du golf
national de saint quentin en yvelines
on y retrouve des informations sur le
golf sur le parcours de l'albatros
considéré par les spécialistes comme
l'un des plus compliqués au monde
on peut jouer également à des jeux mais
également se prendre en photo avec la
ryder cup
il y avait beaucoup de monde il ya
quelques instants
la ryder cup ne se passe pas que sur les
greens à se déroulent également dans les
magasins 135 millions de dollars
devraient être engrangé seulement en
marche et aisin pendant la compétition
le panier moyen d'un américain serait de
100 $ pour les trois jours nous allons
voir ce qu'ils ont dans leur sac
casquette ryder cup ryder cup est en
berne
le programme au pc de la ryder cup on
est vraiment heureux
j'ai un drapeau américain un couvre-
club
un drapeau pourquoi je les ai achetés
pour mon père mon frère ma famille
nous allons désormais voir pascal grizot
l'un des organisateurs de la ryder cup
en france nous allons voir avec lui les
retombées économiques que pour avoir la
ryder cup en france en 2018
d'après les études que nous avons
réalisées en impact direct il ya
l'événement on aurait à peu près 150
millions de création de richesses et en
indirect qu'il faut rajouter à peu près
50% donc un total de 225 millions
d'euros de création de richesses sur un
événement qui est un événement assez
court puisque c'est trois jours de
compétition c'est très important
les dollars ne sont pas seulement
engrangé ici au golf dazelle times comme
vous pouvez le voir derrière moi
l'économie locale est également impactée
à nous allons rencontrer un habitant qui
habite à quelques pas de la ryder cup
il a vu ses recettes doublé depuis trois
jours voilà lorsque je travaille en
dehors de la ville ça n'affecte pas
vraiment mon travail mais je suis
également conducteur de hubert et je
fais des airs bnb dans ma maison j'ai
deux occupants actuellement et je vais
gagner beaucoup d'argent ce week-end
/
k
oh
nous avons être d'être déjà en 2018 et
de faire et peut-être même encore mieux
que ce que nous voyons aujourd'hui ici
aux etats unis
ça vous fait peur de l'organisation
qu'il ya ici à l times ou penser que
saint quentin en yvelines peut faire la
même chose
je pense que nous sommes prêts déjà
relevé le défi nous nous sommes là pour
regarder comment les choses se passent
comme nous l'étions il y a deux ans
aussi en écosse donc on voit que la
cette fois la barre et encore dit biot
et donc c'est à nous à relever ce défi
mais je pense qu'on va tirer beaucoup
d'enseignements de ce que nous voyons
aujourd'hui aux états unis
ils sont très bien me préparer tout ça a
été vraiment très très bien organisée je
dois dire que je suis surpris mais il ya
beaucoup d'enseignements à tirer les
gouvernements qui vont nous servir dans
deux ans à saint quentin en yvelines
la ryder cup 2016 touche à sa fin ici à
chaska dans le minnesota rendez vous en
à saint quentin en yvelines j'ai des
souvenirs plein la tête j'espère que
vous aussi je vous dis au revoir
de mon côté je vais essayer d'avoir un
autographe de tiger woods